afg das steht für alternative für
deutschland der bundesverfassungsschutz
kurz bfv hält die afg allerdings für
eine mögliche bfd eine gefahr für
deutschland weil sie in teilen gegen
unsere verfassung verstossen könnte so
der verdacht deswegen hat der
inlandsgeheimdienst die partei als
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall
eingestuft die hat dagegen geklagt und
verloren der verfassungsschutz kann mit
der beobachtung jetzt loslegen warum
darf er das und was bedeutet das für die
afg ihre mitglieder und den bundestag
bekommen bei einer neuen folge von
inside politics
ich arbeite jetzt schon seit mehreren
jahren im efd ihres vor bei uns im
hauptstadtstudio ich war auf parteitagen
auf hintergründen führe regelmäßig
interviews aber so erschrocken wie hier
habe ich den afg chef gene krupa noch
nie gesehen ja und hat das urteil des
gerichts überrascht wir teilen die
auffassung des gerichtes nicht wenn
jetzt die schriftliche urteilsbegründung
abwarten sollten prüfen inwieweit wir
weitere schritte gegen dieses urteil
vorgehen werden eigentlich so habe es
ist leute aus der afg erzählt war kuba
am 8 märz vor gericht in köln den ganzen
tag über guter dinge und dachte seine
partei gewinnt in 2 punkten hat sie das
übrigens auch der verfassungsschutz darf
den offiziell aufgelösten stramm rechten
parteiflügel nicht mehr als
rechtsextremistisch bezeichnen und auch
nicht mehr auf 7000 mitglieder beziffern
zum flügel und zu seinem ehemaligen chef
jan hoet kommen wir später noch diese
beiden teil erfolge sind aber nur kleine
erfolge dass die afg jetzt 82 gilt auch
dem verfassungsschutz eine ganze menge
mehr er darf unter umständen die
telefone von fd lan abhören ihre mails
lesen v-leute einschleusen und nicht
mehr nur öffentliche äußerungen darauf
prüfen ob sie mit unserer verfassung
vereinbar sind sowie solche zum beispiel
kopftuchmädchen und alimentierte messer
männer und sonstige taugenichts und die
nazis sind nur ein vorschuss
über 1000 jahre erfolgreich
unsere rechtsexpertin saar attacke hat
mir erklärt was die kriterien sind die
zur einstufung als verdachtsfall führen
sarah war beim prozess in köln dabei die
richterin richter am arbeitsgericht köln
haben ganz klar gesagt sie sehen
genügend tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
dafür dass einflussreiche teile der ard
aktuell daran arbeiten die im
grundgesetz garantierte menschenwürde
den rechtsstaat unsere demokratie
schlicht das fundament auf dem unsere
gesellschaft gebaut ist anzugreifen und
auch abzuschaffen und sie sagen die fdp
befindet sich aktuell ein
richtungsstreit und sie könnten nicht
ausschließen dass sich innerhalb darf
die verfassungsfeindlichen strömung am
ende durchsetzen genau damit haben sie
begründet dass der inlandsgeheimdienst
nun die afg beobachten darf um das
herauszufinden ob die fw tmn
verfassungsfeindlich ist wir müssen aber
ganz klar sagen uns haben die richter
auf gesagt wir sind hier in einem
frühwarnsystem das heißt es ist nur ein
verdacht aber es ist eben auch ein
verdacht im verdacht mit krassen folgen
mit sehr krassen folgen das gab es noch
nie die afd ist die erste partei in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik die im
bundestag sitzt und in ihrer gesamtheit
vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird
ganz praktisch kann ihr das ziemlich
schaden afd mitglieder die als richter
als lehrer als polizisten arbeiten also
beamte sind staatsdiener für die könnte
es nun wirklich unbequem werden denn
beamte staatsdiener sind zur
verfassungstreue verpflichtet und genau
diese verfassungstreue steht er jetzt in
frage auch für die mitglieder der afd
deshalb könnten behörden nun diese
entscheidung zum anlass nehmen gegen
polizisten lehrer richter die fdp
mitglieder sind disziplinarverfahren
einzuleiten
man muss aber ganz klar sagen das sind
immer einzelfallprüfung und es muss in
dem einzelfall noch was da hinzukommen
was die verfassungstreue fraglich macht
das heißt es wird jetzt nicht
automatisch gegen jedes mitglied des
beamtet habe abend wird es um das
verfahren einleitet aber diese
möglichkeit die besteht und deshalb wird
das vermutlich auch dazu führen oder
kann dazu führen
kfd mitglieder aus der partei austreten
nicht nur beamter beamtete und natürlich
auch dass ich auf die wähler von der
partei abwenden und jetzt stehen auch
noch landtagswahlen vor der tür da wird
man das erste mal sehen wie es der
partei damit so geht die streitet gerade
zwar auch über ihre haltung zu russland
und wie wir hören sogar ziemlich heftig
auch das könnte in die wahlergebnisse
einfließen aber das ist ein anderes
thema wie will die afg nun verhindern
dass sie abstürzt eine taktik keine
große überraschung sie greift auf das
erklärungsmuster manche sagen die
verschwörungstheorie zurück auf das sie
eigentlich schon immer zurückgegriffen
hat seitdem sich die verfassungsschützer
in bund und ländern für sie
interessieren ein paar tage nach dem
kölner urteil hatte die
bundestagsfraktion der afg eine klausur
in thüringen drei tage lang da haben wir
die fraktionschefs abgepasst und sie
gefragt wie sie jetzt mit ein bisschen
abstand auf die gerichtsentscheidung
schauen es ist ja auch ein rein
politisches urteil zu bewerten also uns
jetzt als partei so einzustufen das ist
natürlich ein wie soll ich sagen eine
wettbewerbs benachteiligung eines
politischen konkurrenten wenn sie dann
noch sehen wer der chef des
verfassungsschutzes ist es ist jemand
mit dem cdu parteibuch und
dementsprechend hat das ganze urteil und
das ganze verfahren natürlich auch ein
entsprechendes geschmäckle gut nun
regiert die cdu zwar gar nicht mehr und
die entscheidung dass der
verfassungsschutz die afg als verdacht
zwei beobachten darf hat er als auch ein
gericht getroffen trotzdem die partei
fühlt sich ungerecht behandelt wir haben
ja in den letzten monaten und eigentlich
auch schon jahren viele dinge ja auch
schon proaktiv gemacht also wir haben
wenns grenzüberschreitungen in gegeben
hat und die gab es das bestreitet bei
uns auch niemand haben wir auch der
harte sanktionen durchgespielt und auch
natürlich auch durchgesetzt in der
partei habt ihr alle zweites gesicht
gesehen so einig sind sich die beiden da
offensichtlich nicht weil man übrigens
auch nicht im fall von andreas keil den
hat der verfassungsschutz als offen
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft genauso
wie bahnhöfe und hans thomas till
schneider stellvertretender chef der afg
in sachsen anhalt tillschneider und
theke werden
als personen vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet jenseits ihrer arbeit in den
parlamenten das passiert nicht oft und
zeigt für wie gefährlich der
inlandsgeheimdienst sie hält zurück so
andreas kalbitz den hat die fdp zwei
jahren rausgeschmissen wegen seiner
nazi-vergangenheit da war man sich im
parteivorstand übrigens gar nicht mal so
eilig ob man ihm seine mitgliedschaft
aberkennen sollte wie es ganz präzise
heißen muss und wenn man sich in der
partei um hört ist es sehr erstaunlich
wie gut vernetzt cables dort immer noch
ist er ist auch immer noch regelmäßig
bei veranstaltungen seiner ehemaligen
freunde von der afg dabei zuletzt bei
einem aktionstag gegen die impfpflicht
in magdeburg anfang märz kallwitz
mittendrin auch in den herzen seiner
kumpels oder in ihren armen sowie in dem
fall ihr habt ihn wahrscheinlich schon
wieder erkannt hans-thomas till
schneider geiwitz klagt gegen seinen
rauswurf aus der afg und mancher sagen
hinter vorgehaltener hand dass sie ihn
gern zurück hätten das wäre dann noch
mal ein anlass dafür die partei zu
beobachten der verfassungsschutz hat
kalbitz und hätte schon vor zwei jahren
als erwiesen rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft da gibt es nicht mal mehr
lediglich ein verdacht sondern der ist
bestätigt wie gesagt der
verfassungsschutz darf die afg ab sofort
beobachten auch wenn die gegen das
urteil in berufung gehen will sollte es
bei der beobachtung bleiben hat das ganz
konkrete auswirkungen auch auf die
arbeit des bundestags haben erst der in
politiker anderer parteien schon
angekündigt dass der verfassungsschutz
diese partei als verdachtsfall einstuft
das ist ein relevanter auch
sicherheitspolitischer vorgang und er
wirft natürlich fragen auf auch für den
deutschen bundestag selbst zum beispiel
bei der geheimdienst kontrolle in dieses
urteil
letztinstanzlich bestätigt ist ist das
natürlich nicht möglich dass eine partei
die als verdachtsfall eingestuft ist
mitglied im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium ist das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium ist ein gremium des
bundestages dass die geheimdienste
überwacht die mitglieder erhalten
brisante papiere und
sicherheitsrelevante informationen
gewählt wird das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium von den abgeordneten des
bundestages wenn sich jetzt also die
anderen fraktionen absprechen können sie
der afd
einen sitz im kontrollgremium verwehren
genau das ist zu anfang der
legislaturperiode übrigens genauso bei
der besetzung unter anderem des
innenausschusses passiert auch ein
absolutes novum in der geschichte des
parlaments die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
also relativ hoch dass dasselbe wieder
passiert diesmal beim pkgr wie sich das
kontrollgremium abkürzt also kommen wir
zum fazit für manche mitglieder der afg
kann es jetzt ungemütlich werden für die
fdp wird es das ganz sicher die will das
urteil nicht hinnehmen
eigentlich logisch und in die nächste
instanz gehen die afg wäre aber nicht
die afg wenn sie sich bis dahin nicht
weiter streiten würde besonders wenn sie
es bei den wahlen abspielen sollte es
bleibt also interessant apropos
interessant hat euch diese folge
gefallen dann lasst ein leichter und
abonniert uns dafür versprechen wir euch
dass ihr euch auf dem laufenden halten
auch was die afg angeht bis zum nächsten
mal